I don't think my hair is cooperating
with me okay you're right you have five
minutes to make the best creature
possible it's almost sort of different
uh it's a thing everybody you like it's
nipple legs well that looks quick do you
have any idea what you're doing you go
to the you do realize you go to the same
place
again and again and again yes oh yeah
yeah yeah we know yes
stop stop just stop one gene oh yes yes
yes yes yes okay now bring the tail up
through the legs whoa whoa bring the
tail ball oh yeah yes yes yes yeah yes
yes okay stop stop no no no no touch the
tail yeah okay yeah okay
Oh what was that
Oh God it smiled at me oh hello
everybody my name is markiplier wait
hang on my hair is not okay don't laugh
at me don't laugh at me
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sport with Wade and
Tyler Tyler just got done seeing genius
here and making Smokies now you know why
spike oh yeah exactly
Sookie he's ready to enter the world and
see the world of slippin no gun smiled I
know God was cute except for its huge
spiky dick I guess I'm gone now God
strut we got going on turn it up to the
Sun so you got like a nice view of the
sunset no I mean like walk away from the
Sun what that you know you were walking
yeah what way did change Tyler
the Sun is gone Tyler the Sun and the
keys are gone the second I think you
have an inkling of what to do right away
run away run away
you're gonna kill you don't want to get
killed okay let everyone else do its
thing cuz you're fighting your home base
okay turn around
I guards
you have no words I know welcome back
everybody the beginning of the episode
because nothing happened alright now
that we got our fresh body we're about
to go explore the world and hunt some
monsters alright then that's just us
being peppy to get started go Tyler go
can you tell like our speed is so
improved
I mean I'm amazed at this speed that we
have leave that horny [ __ ] I'm
proudly displaying his pain he just sung
you want to sing in return
that's sing as one dancer - you might
dance after this that's it oh oh that is
seductive I wish I could see it cuz the
camera angle you know yeah but whatever
- OH
Oh much better now that it's over oh
yeah cut him off that's great - whatever
you know I've always thought the YouTube
wasn't really a visual medium people
don't need to see the things that you
want them to see or whatever it's okay
you all right they're great oh good
we're done Hey look another guy dance
with him/her you might want to face him
no it's your choice
really it is Oh take your time not a
rush raving now bye good job Tyler it's
good you got a homie you now need to go
pound some
skis and pound some other native species
into the ground congratulations
welcome back everybody to spore glad you
could join us here we did our goal and
we did it well I hope that is in the
shadow of the giant looming monster
behind us I bet if we will turn around
in the next two minutes yeah cuz like
I've said before seeing the thing isn't
as nearly fun as knowing it's there
oh there it is blending in with the
background just as good as the close-up
we could have had
oh yeah charge right for it that's a
brilliant idea
whatever what do I know ah yeah oh look
it's a big thing great cool don't look
at it though look look at it that's one
it's gonna get you whatever you eat that
thing
there's his arm that's as much as we've
ever seen
whatever my jacket something great cool
that's great
you know what's attacking something else
the big thing that'd be cool to see or
not whatever oh right yeah now run pilot
Robyn what are you either what it killed
your friend Tyler ha
he's going away from his home away from
his home so far away in the exact
opposite direction of the way that he
could go face Tyler bones bones bones a
Steiner bone face I really hope this is
funny otherwise it's gonna see me did
your dick grow I think you did change
Oh spikey is very smart now
very smart now I can probably up to all
people oh yeah good observation there
look Tyler we know now go back home you
know we love you they love you too I'm
in a lot of pain for laughing again yes
you are thank you everybody for watching
we're gonna continue playing spore and
maybe get something done amazingly so
see in the next part and as always I'll
see you in the next part I'm losing my
mind entire game with the right
direction you're like oh yeah go home
just stops I thought you were dick you
thought you were messing with me yeah I
spot your intentionally
shut up you know our mother or the
complicated man alright fine that one